today we are tidying with filmmaker Matt
Jarboe he's been he's been paying
attention there is a little bit to our
release of goodbye promise and we're
just we're just gonna thrust right into
this one without warning without
hesitation so Matt when did you first
come across the campaign and some of
your early thoughts with with what we're
doing releasing the film on IndieGoGo I
found you guys well I've known you guys
for a couple years now and I follow you
guys on Twitter on Facebook and I knew
you'd made the movie but I didn't quite
know what you were doing with it until
you released the the IndieGoGo campaign
and when I checked it out being a person
has made a couple features myself and
not really known the distribution market
I just fell in love with what you guys
are doing I think it's probably one of
the best things I've seen anyone in the
indie market actually attempt to do
because you're controlling it you're not
just like putting it out there and
saying hey hey hope you watch my movie
come on guys it's awesome you guys are
really using everything at your disposal
to get the word out and that's awesome I
mean so and you're actually one of the
early filmmakers to hit us back and say
you know what you know I'm really sort
of digging this and I'm actually
considering this for my phone you know
do you want to share some of those
thoughts with us yeah um I made my first
film two years ago and I made it you
know two days for 500 bucks we kind of
just went out made it and I didn't have
a plan I figured I would just shoot it
see what happened you know it's been two
and a half years I haven't done anything
with it and I want people to see it I
mean it's up for free right now people
can watch it but it's like not getting a
lot of views I'm thinking maybe if we
kind of up the ante and you know
parlayed that into like raising funds
for another film that I have a script
I've just recently finished that I want
to make that could be a good way to kind
of beef up my public personality as well
as getting the name of the film out
there and then you know raising
awareness for a new project I guess
first off of me Congrats on making the
film you know we don't want an
accomplishment that is it's pretty
extraordinary
to say you shot it in two days but but
but how long did you stay in post
because no matter how long the shooting
schedule is it's still going to take a
lot of effort to see it all the way
through
well post was a complicated problem I
had an editor that I had a falling-out
with a semi falling-out with and she
kind of finished the project but then
gave me all the files and if I wanted to
do more - but I'm not a Mac person I
only have PC so everything was in final
cut so I had to find another editor and
I had met a college kid who was like oh
I'll do it for free you know as
experience and I'm like well
everything's pretty much here but we
weren't able to get to the final cut
files so it took him a long time to
piece the movie back together
the way she did it and then modify a few
things along the way it took about a
year and a half - and it was it's a 72
minute movie you know it just it took so
long to put it together it's like yeah
you have this thing that you shoot in
two days and then it still takes a year
and a half to get done and and then and
then really in an IU pack the
distribution is just beginning at that
point can you tell us like the
challenges and the hurdles that you
faced once you got the film done and
then and then sort of what the options
were you were looking at were at that
time yeah it's um you know a movie like
might like in search of its point of
view found footage similar to Paranormal
Activity right and there's a lot of
movies like that being made right now
and people are capitalizing on the
success of that franchise as well as
like you know Blair Witch and whatnot
and I it's my first feature I'm not an
actor and I'm what you know the co-star
and I directed it and I produced it and
my lead actor was my my in real life
best friend so well I think we had a
good chemistry I I was always kind of
afraid of putting it out there in a
competitive capacity so I just said you
know it was such a it was just a proof
of concept of movies like I want to make
so let's just give it away for free
since it didn't really cost much to make
and let's let's just let people see it
and then I'll burn DVDs and give them
copies of it and I got some really good
feedback from people and now I'm just
like maybe I should take it that next
step and and try to put it out there
more not just disregard it as fastly as
I did in the first place so Matt when
you were in that year-and-a-half in
post-production what were there times
where you want to just just totally give
it up I mean did you wrestle with that
back and forth I was I was really angry
at my first editor because it felt like
I got kind of hosed because the drive
that I got all the files back on
I couldn't access I went through 15
people to try to access this drive and
we couldn't get it to work it was like
it just shut down and there was an also
a project on there that I had made in
2007 that we needed to finish up a
little bit on and I can't even do
anything more with that so those files
are gone you know we did this movie five
years ago and it was a school project
that we are wanting to kind of you know
revisit and fix that's all gone I was
very frustrated and I didn't have the
money to finish it the way I wanted to
so I kind of had to go with people that
would help me out of the kindness of
their heart so I'm not mad at that but
it's like I couldn't do all that I
wanted to do with it right right we
understand that yeah so that sounds like
then there were times did you just say
you know what I'm not sure I'm gonna
finish this and then other mornings you
got up and you said no I want to finish
this but yeah it was kind of like I had
to you know I was working on my second
feature at the time we kind of started
talking about doing another movie in the
theater that I worked out in Pasadena so
that kind of got me revamped to get back
in there and so I started kind of really
pushing my editor to finish it and he
right before Comic Con in 2011 last year
he had finished a copy of the film that
I was going to burn off like a hundred
discs up and just give out at comic-con
so he burns off a hundred discs and
because he lives like really really east
out by like you know San Bernadino so I
couldn't get out to his place to vet the
disc there were problems with it all
hundred copies had errors and they
weren't like disk errors they were stuff
in the movie that should have been
removed that he overlooked so I have a
hundred copies of my film that I can't
do anything with
so that frustrated me even more and then
I push them harder to fix it and get it
done so we could just move on from there
you know I've been down the same path
Mac so I you know I totally understand
what it's like you know I mean it from
our point of view it's like when you
have limited resources we have limited
money and there's so much you want to do
with your project and it's going to take
a lot of energy it's going to take a lot
of work a lot of time yeah that's why
it's hard to push these editors who are
forward Talent the story that's hard
it's hard to drag them along for the
journey that we ourselves are ready to
go on but you know when you're dealing
with limited time limited money it's
like you almost I would almost advise
like you know at our level just you know
almost know like to start with you're
going to just have this editor on board
as long as you can carry him you know as
long as that's like the next the next
movie I make I'm gonna have part of the
budget okay this piece is for the editor
only that's it but not gonna screw this
around we're gonna do it Kickstarter
campaign just for the thought about it
talk about it and so so even with that I
mean did you attempt I mean how much how
much energy did you put in to film
festivals was that something and did you
try and get it in some of the top-tier
film festivals I I have a very
controversial thought about film
festivals which is 95% of them are crap
and they're just a for-profit system
wanting to take your money and this
comes from having worked with festivals
when I worked at the theater we hosted
festivals so I caught a lot of inside
information on how they operate and and
how they just a lot of times people
there don't care they act like they care
because they want you to submit your
films and submit your money and I don't
want to do that I would rather I have
spent a couple years building my social
media presents you with like flash or
shorts my personal account and
everything but I could take this to my
fans and then just promote it through
them and then that way I'm taking it to
the people that I know would want to see
it and maybe I'd have a better shot then
then going the festival route because I
can't afford to submit you know a
hundred bucks per
every time it hope that I gets you know
screen by maybe 3040 people you know
from our perspective you know there's a
lot of things we love about film
festivals I mean some people may think
that we're against film festivals you
know with this film we decided to bypass
that way simply because you know we
weren't sure at what level because you
know really you need to get into one of
those top film festivals and then if you
don't then you know they're not my
opinion is like you know you really
could just be wasting your time you know
and then and then sort of like the that
level of what you're gonna get out of it
it quickly sort of goes down you know
once you get beyond those like 12 15
film festivals you're just not going to
get as much out of it and and and you
know we just thought like hey if we can
get it just if we can get it to people
directly right now we just rather do
that and see what we can do what exactly
virtual unknown I think you know dipping
your toe in the water with festivals
even if you don't get to the top 15 is
good it's kind of like it so it's a
win-win yeah maybe they use you for the
money but you also use them for the
exposure so it's you know everybody uses
everybody kind of thing that's and
that's the sad thing about the industry
it really is everybody uses everybody
you know it yeah totally true but if you
can even get traffic on their websites
until people know who you are but then
again if you've already kind of done
this side route where you build your own
following on your own so it's like at
what level do you say I don't need
festivals anymore and that's and I think
that's if you're able to establish a
relationship with a distribution company
like you know on your own you can pretty
much bypass the festival circuit the
second feature that I did we have a
distribution agreement with an
international company that handled the
directors previous couple films so you
know I'm not too worried about the
second feature and then I'm currently
doing social media for a big Hollywood
production through a new production
company that's also an international
distribution company so I'm working
directly with these guys and trying to
find ways to go like hey watch watch my
movie that's my you know
and so I'm trying that route first
because that's kind of the world I find
myself in at the moment I guess I just
wanted to come back to this this point
of view that where you know here you are
you decide you know what film festivals
are not for me you end up sort of
finding this place where you're like
okay I'm just gonna give my movie away
for free I mean did you have sort of
wandering thoughts about like hey
putting this out on crowdfunding is that
something that ever flashed through your
mind well I when I financed the movie I
did it through crowdfunding but I didn't
use IndieGoGo or Kickstarter I had
literally five days to do pre-production
all pre-production on the movie and so I
built a website and I put PayPal on
there and I asked all my friends and
family and I raised the money in two
days and and doing that like that I
learned that I won saves more money
because I didn't have to pay any of the
fees and I knew I had a reasonable
budget and I had enough passion behind
my project where it was able to attract
the people and and get them to help me
and that's kind of how I view most
crowdfunding now is is you know
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo they're they
have a lot of traffic and they get a lot
of attention but how many campaigns do
we see that aren't fully prepared
I'm not referencing you guys of course
I'm just in general doing research I've
come across a lot of these campaigns
that they don't give you the full
synopsis not even anything really to
whet your whistle and their budgets are
weight really high and they're not
broken down and you can tell like a line
producer didn't come in so it's kind of
like they put them they put it out there
and it makes me not want to give them
money because I know they're not
prepared which then I in turn use that
internally saying I don't want to ask
for money unless I'm prepared and that's
when I get further along with my current
film I'm gonna you know I'm gonna use
that but I'm gonna make sure everything
is in order before I even hit the submit
button and I'm curious what are some of
the flags that you see what you want to
call them red flags where you can tell
that they're not prepared you said you
can tell sort of when you don't feel
like there's a line producer involved so
maybe the budget isn't clear
in this gonna I this is hey I know this
is a recent one but four of a kind
Jack Marseille I know you guys really
pushed that and I believed in it i
retweeted it a lot too but I watched
through his videos and I just right
before we did this I watched his one
about why he needed a hundred thousand
dollars he didn't he says he needed it
because that's what he felt he needed
and that to me as a potential investor
is like well why do you eat it because
this is all going in the movie what's
the breakdown here you know I looked at
his breakdown and it didn't feel very
well put together so I was weary to want
to give any money because I just didn't
know and I see that a lot even with a
friend of mine doing a Kickstarter right
now he did a his Kickstarter video told
me nothing about the movie and nothing
about you know why he wanted to do it it
was just like a video of you should make
a movie but not selling me on why I
should feel his why should resonate with
his passion you know and that's kind of
my thoughts and I see a lot of these
videos or people just throw out money
they throw it numbers and they don't
understand why they're necessary and so
I can't as a person who's you know
budgeted films and worked on them I
can't get behind that if they just took
a little bit more time and really
focused it and and came back with a
proper business plan that would make me
as a potential investor even as a
donator feel more comfortable with
giving away my money to support your
dream because you're prepared enough to
follow through with it and in terms of
like the IndieGoGo page or the
Kickstarter page that has the campaign
on it do you think that less is more or
do you think that the more photos and
more information the better or is it
over Kate I think treating it like the
treating the front page almost like a
trailer like a teaser it's good so have
you have any mock you know like the
photos are good of your cast maybe a
mock teaser that you've had made up some
some graphic design work whatever sell
me on your idea in the first you know
one third of the page because if you're
doing like tons of descriptions you know
people don't have an interest past about
three minutes so reading these lines you
know you get kind of lost in it whereas
if you have something short to the point
you know between two to three minutes
long that sells me on your idea even if
you're just talking into a camera but
you tell me your story tell me your why
you want to make this and you show me
you know why you're passionate that
would resonate better with me and then
when you have your update page if you
hook me enough you look on your update
page and you see what you've done since
then and that to me would get more
people involved because it shows that
you're concise in your presentation and
then they want to go and learn more
about the project whereas if you throw
all the information out there at first
people might get lost in it get confused
I mean how much time do you have to
spend on Kickstarter you know is it
in-between your lunch break are you
before dinner things like that you know
and how about you come to us a little
bit mad you know when you look at our
campaign we're trying to learn here as
well you know and we don't you know
claim to have everything perfect so you
know it's good you know so when you look
at our campaign what are some things
that you like and what are some things
that you don't like Oh looking at your
guys's campaign I like the video in the
front of it you know I like that you
guys have the actors and you guys
talking about the film and why it's
important to you i I really resonated
with that that to me spoke volumes about
your project the fact that you say it's
not about the money that's another thing
because that shows that you guys are not
just trying to make a quick buck off
this you know you believe in your
product enough you're asking for a
minimal donation but you're effectively
giving it away for free and I and I can
get behind that 100% because in this
business we can easily tell if someone's
just trying to sell us something but if
you come across and you guys have always
been true to form very very hard on your
sleeve we see passion and it's it comes
through so much with you guys that it
makes it makes you want to give it makes
you want to help because we know that
you're being genuine and that's you know
important in this world because we see
so many people get screwed over and get
hurt and not want to trust but we don't
have that problem with you guys because
you really you're genuine that's the
best I can say about that I like what
you guys have done to the point of where
I really just want to model it no I I
was saying I have a feeling before
before we finish this that someone else
will in and thank you I mean that's the
sincerest form of flattery that's really
cool thank you Matt
no you're welcome I believe in you guys
I really you know I need to donate and
watch the movie that's the other thing
I'm waiting for a couple of checks to
come in i dollars are hard but anyway
you know I mean it's like but I want to
see it I saw the trailer it looks really
good I can I really kind of resonate
with the idea because as you posted on
Twitter last night you know when do you
when should you give up your dream like
do you have to give up your dream and
I've been here for two and a half years
and you know like I'm working on it
daily but it's just as a person living
in the city and trying to get ahead in
this industry it resonates and you you
have to question it all the time and you
know so that's why I support really
support what you guys have done in terms
in terms of the film I mean you know
that that's what it is it's it's a
heartfelt story as a personal story it's
us sort of turning the camera on
ourselves you know we've been out here
in LA much longer than two or three
years you know you're out here and you
you know you put so much time and energy
into something now you put so much time
and energy into sort of like this this
big dream that you've had you know and
in our case it really just boils down to
our passion our love for for independent
film you know making small films wanting
to parlay that into something that we
could do for a long time and and you
know life often gets in the way there's
a lot a lot of things that happen but at
the same time there's also a lot of
sacrifice on our end and and we keep you
know every day we just try to pick
ourselves up and keep adding and keep
pushing forward
so I various thoughts there I completely
agree I mean we we have to though the
change in the industry in the last
couple years has been insane we have
more at our fingertips now than ever
before we have more ways to distribute
our films to people who want to see them
than ever before it's just I read an
article last year that said 50,000 films
are made feature films are made
worldwide like in 2011 and how do you
compete with that you know you have to
think outside the box you have to know
your audience
know how to target them talk to them
communicate with them engage with them
do everything that you do would do with
social media but treat it like you know
you would for your film is just build
that relationship and get that fan base
and so when you move forward you have
people to bring with you that support
you and I think that's what not of a lot
of people teach anymore and and that's
kind of where it is a very social
environment we have to really work
towards helping each other you know like
the like the Jack Morris ad for of a
kind of thing that was amazing to watch
unfold and I'm very sorry he didn't
reach his goal that was amazing to watch
people from all over web and all over
Twitter come together for one cause for
one person to help them because you
believed in that and that's why we do it
you know yeah I mean it was trending on
time sure yeah that it was trending on
Twitter and I didn't see some of it go
down on on Twitter cuz I was doing
emails at the same time and the tweet
deck will distract me so I have to close
down because I have like I'll be like oh
look at this look at this so I had to
close down here and there but um yeah it
was it was phenomenal I mean yeah I mean
one experience you know what I think I
think what you're tapping into there you
know it you know I know you know you
know I think there's science you know
from from us getting to know Jack over
the you know the past couple months here
you know there are signs of him maybe
not having the complete plan you know
but at the same time it you know he's in
a spot where we're on a day-to-day basis
he's losing his eyesight you know so it
just gets to a point where you're gonna
just have to pull the trigger and just
sort of go for it and put it all on the
line even if you're not all the way
ready yet and I think we saw such a
great response because the story is
there you know and I think you know
something we're learning you know and
we're trying to share as much as we can
as we release goodbye the promise is we
think when it comes to crowdfunding too
many people are getting caught up with
their idea and with the the movie or the
project they want to make their caught
up with the amount of money they want to
raise and really what's being lost there
is is also the story that's being told
you know the
story not just of the movie but your own
personal story and I think the reason
why we saw such a tremendous rally for
Jack is because his story is so
compelling and it's not it's hard not to
root for that sort of underdog and and
and you know it's just like you know any
of us that are creative you know to lose
one of our senses that would you know
essentially disable us from doing
something I mean it really I mean for me
both of my parents are deaf so I've
grown up in that sort of environment you
know and I just you know so coming from
that perspective just really connected
with Jack's story and just just did all
we can all we could to see it through
yeah I completely agree I'm pretty sure
I'll get the movie made
we hope he gets the movie made yeah yeah
I mean when also in keeping with a story
behind sort of the story if you have a
chance to see sleepwalk with me Mike
Birbiglia and Ira Glass of this American
Life it's a great film it's a comedy but
it's also has sort of that kind of
goodbye promise feel to it in a like it
way in that it's about a guy who's been
doing stand-up and he's in his late 20s
30s and you know all his friends and
family around and we're all excelling in
other careers and he's you know taking
out the trash and his work and and
getting all this pressure from people so
it's a great film and it's about like do
you give up and and do you keep going
kind of thing and so if you have a
chance to see you know I think you'd
like it
no I read about it and Entertainment
Weekly this week and I do want to see it
I didn't know about it before and I was
like oh I can get behind this I I know
what this is like yeah I think you'd
love it so anyway and that film also
made me think just because there were as
many parts that they're very funny but
also very painfully funny because
there's a lot of truth in it and yeah I
think you can join I'll just leave it at
that
but I guess what I was saying was
there's a story behind because it's
loosely based on his own journey Mike
Birbiglia his own journey in comedy and
things like that so that's what's
fascinating about it is that he weaves
in a lot of stuff from his own life into
the yeah we just posted a very short
video interview that we did was that
yesterday yeah yeah
along with everything yeah yeah we do as
he said a quick sit-down interview and
it was it was interesting at the at the
end of the interview you know they
talked about you know the movies being
released through IFC and IFC was able to
get the movie into 30 theaters across
the country and an hourglass who was
also the host of this American Life is a
co-writer and producer on the film and
then and he has his own following and
then mike has his own following on
Twitter and on Facebook and on UNIX one
day from from doing comedy all the years
and so they reached out to their own
social networks and and essentially got
their people their fans their audience
to request the film and so the theater
count went from 30 theaters done by IFC
which is no small feat in itself all the
way up to 150 theaters now and
potentially still growing so it's kind
of cool and it might kind of did the
video saying like like essentially what
we did there in terms of just doing all
we can sort of spreading the word and
and and using our passion and our belief
and what we're doing and spreading the
word he's like that's basically what
I've been doing my whole career and it
was like a great way to end the video
and you know it comes back around to us
in terms of that's what we're trying to
do you know we've been building with
some courage glass through the years and
now we just decided you know we're just
going to go direct to our people however
many people that turns out to be you
know if our films strong enough and and
our work from the past is strong enough
then then maybe you know we can create
some momentum and and create more waves
with the film this way rather than sort
of stalling and going the film festival
route or any other route you know let's
just see what we can do on our own so
that's kind of you know no I completely
agree I've been at the point now where
I'm thinking about dressing up like
Silent Bob and going down to Hollywood
Boulevard and kind of melding in with
all the players because I can kind of
look like Kevin Smith a little bit and
then just hanging out you know like
flyers go hey check out my new movie
check out my new movie and people might
think oh Kevin Smith has a new movie you
know I'm like I'm not saying anything
you know it could happen and then just
get people to watch it that way and then
go and like buy the DVD or buy the
digital
copy or just I don't know pirate it and
show your friends I don't care do you
want you want to talk a little bit about
you've been doing this week care no no
oh you want me to tell people I think
it's fine because we're putting it all
out there David has had copies of his
short-films shoot out which is a great
short film
Tyshawn Bryant Daniels soul isn't it but
they've been sitting sitting in this
room in our house for like what five
years
probably yeah like five years inside
there's how many copies I don't know
there's probably 500 copies of DVDs and
they're nicely packaged to wrap they're
beautifully done so I'm like look why
don't we do a couple things why don't we
get rid of them in that I make a little
flyer on top like this little piece of
paper that says if you like this film
also by David Brennan's other film for
one dollar by going to goodbye promise
calm which you know we kind of put a
brief synopsis and things like that so I
tape it on there and I've just been
leaving them places I left them out red
boxes I left them at 7-eleven I go to
people's houses and put them on their
doorstep I left them um wait we're in
front of the gym I mean just anywhere I
can and I do it in a way that I don't
engage anybody because people think I'm
passing out like religious literature
and they don't want to deal with me
which is great so I just pretend like
you know what and I don't try to sell
them on it I just put it down and I know
I can sense their like what's she doing
and then they I see I look back and
they're gone so who knows if they're
even watching them it hasn't had like a
outpour of money coming I think we've
only put out what 60 yeah something like
maybe a hundred this has only been in
the last I think I started doing it on
Sunday but people were definitely like
what what is this woman doing and I like
the best was at the red box there was a
guy in his car and I just leave two DVDs
by the red boxes he spoke about what is
this woman doing and then I look at a
second later and one of them's gone and
I'm pretty sure it was the guy so anyway
long story short we're giving something
to someone whether they like it or not
but we're not pushing it on them they're
finding their own discovery with it I'm
not I'm not coming up to them like I
have literature on you know how to be
saved or whatever and and and they're
they're you know they're they're taking
it and and on their own accord they're
like oh she has something she left on
the ground okay great
so we'll see you know we'll see what it
does but yeah it's just it's a way to
kind of get rid of the DVDs get the word
out about the film and also give
something to someone where they go all
right well maybe I'll check it out yeah
and we can't tell we might have gotten
one sale from friends the DVD so far
it's it's hard to totally gauge but it
seems like there might have been one
that that might have that might have
actually supported the new movie based
on this old short film so it's pretty
cool anything helps as long as you're
not giving people the watchtower I think
they're you know susceptible to help you
out people think that's what I'm doing
because I want to do is I have this huge
hat that I wear like I just and I have
this bag and people are like who is a
strange woman and then I go and I leave
from places like you know wherever in
front of Ralph's or wherever and
obviously one I won't leave like a
tunnel just leave maybe one or two and
they seem to be gone when we come back
so maybe we're chucking him in the trash
I don't know but it's it's a better way
for us to throw away the DVDs well
that's I've had friends do similar
things with short films that they've
made after trying to get it into
Sundance and it failed he just like had
all these DVDs and he's like screw it
just giving him out and he kind of gave
up making movies after that which is
kind of weird but it's just you know he
does some people it's a good way to you
people to see your stuff people love
being given free stuff especially if
it's a movie because then they don't
feel bad about it you know and yeah
listen I mean if you've already gotten
one sale that's a start yeah I mean the
thing is - we don't I don't try it
because I used to do like supermarket
demos back in the day and all that and I
know people are just like oh no please I
don't want to be sold anything so what I
do is I I don't approach them with it
and I leave it somewhere and I know I
can sense it
like what is she doing and then they go
are they finding on their own so they
don't even feel like they're being sold
it they don't feel like I'm hard selling
them on you know buy this you've got to
see this movie and they have their own
process of discovery with it so it's a
sort of a social experiment it's also a
way to clean out the room and it's also
a way to get out worried about the movie
yeah yeah so it's a win-win
yes exactly everybody uses everybody I'm
putting that on a t-shirt t-shirt you
know though you know what that's from
it's from staying alive Finola Hughes
says that to John Travolta it's the best
scene in the movie this still rings true
thirty years later so we're so mad if
you are looking at what we're doing and
considering it do you have any questions
to us in terms of here we are and we've
pretty much things the halfway point now
we've been doing this for for 15 days
and we have 15 days left so we're right
smack dab in the middle and anything
you'd like to know from us yeah like you
know how often have you found like with
with posting and social networks like
what's your best you know rate you guys
like sometimes post more one day unless
another day to kind of gauge out where
you get the best response or what times
work best for you you know I it's
interesting on our end because you know
we certainly had a nice little flurry at
the beginning and certainly this past
week it has slowed down here in our
second week but at the same time you
know we were building momentum we ended
up on the front page of IndieGoGo for
for an entire week and we made an
unusual decision to stop pushing our own
campaign at that time to see if we can
push JAC marchetti's campaign so so
that's where maybe it's a little unusual
you know and so here we are after sort
of not reaching that goal with Jack and
now we're trying to you know build the
energy and get ourselves back up and
sort of you know regain some of them
will immense them that we have lost
because that whole week that we were on
the front page of IndieGoGo featured was
a week that we weren't even
really strongly pushing the campaign but
you know it's also a mixture of what
we're doing you know we're doing some
stuff on Twitter we're doing some stuff
on Facebook and then we're also doing a
lot of emails behind the scenes you know
we're doing a lot of these video
interviews I'm sorry I think that's the
key one was the emails like personally
not a BCC to a bunch of people like hey
friends you know check Nate I think
personal emails of people dear so-and-so
I think that usually works better people
don't want to feel like they're part of
a cluster they want to feel like our
individual yeah yeah exactly yeah you
know and that's a big part of our
strategy is to there's the email people
personally one by one and you sort of
hope that as the campaign comes down to
what close that maybe some of this this
early work we've been doing in the first
two weeks and hopefully that that'll pay
off in the last in the last ten days
yeah and also to I mean it's hard to say
because we have a platform but even in
that it doesn't always work I mean we're
putting out content and within each
piece of content we put out oh hey check
out you know an actor gives himself
seven years and then there's a photo and
all this stuff and even with that it's
not guaranteed so it's really hard to
say for me I think personal emails work
the best and also engagement on social
media like actual one-on-one engagement
not just hey guys check out my movie but
deer at so-and-so and then talking to
them and all that but I think that's
probably I think that personalized
approach well that it's always best
especially in a situation like this
where you guys are trying something new
it's how do you do it I mean you're not
really asking for people to help you
make your movie you've already done that
you've done the hard part now you're
asking people to watch it and if they
like it or well to donate a dollar and
then watch the movie you know which is
really kind of difficult in its own
right but it's not as pressure some full
whatever you want to call it as as
asking for the funds to make the film in
the first place yeah that's true because
they're actually getting something
instantaneously rather than having to
wait two years what are three years in
our case to have it a finished product
so yeah that's a good point they are
getting something
and that's our culture in a nutshell so
they play back up yeah no exactly
exactly so we'll see how this social
experiment works with the DVDs but but
it is interesting because a lot of times
I think people just throw away a flyer
and this they're actually getting
something I mean there were a few people
that I actually went up to but I think
it just was like one or two people and
they were like cool but they seemed like
they'd be a basketball fan so in the
movies a basketball short so I gave them
that but I think a combination of stuff
but even with that and even having a
platform and even having a large social
media following still there's no
guarantee with it you know so it's
really I think in a nutshell it's really
tough to get your movie out there I
think it's just really hard but every
little bit chips away at something and
that's all you can really do at this
point in time is just hope for the best
and keep trying and never give up let's
the line from super troopers are
necessary Starship Troopers never give
up never surrender something I want to
do is put a bunch of movie slogans on
t-shirts cuz I can make all that stuff
myself but you know mo was at Peter
Shankman he started at that's how he did
it right the Titanic well what was it
though it was like he made these
t-shirts anyone wouldn't say like get
over it it sank or something like that
and then he handed them out in Times
Square or he'd charge like a $5 for them
and he made a bunch of money yeah you
know $10 and made it made a killing in a
day and yeah and yeah and that's what
his story evolved from there and he's
going on to a lot of success so yeah you
know I don't know do you have any any
any further questions beyond that Matt
have you guys had a lot of having like a
bigger increase in views for the film I
mean like have you guys gotten a lot
because you've had a couple hundred
downloads or I mean donators so I like
your view count gone up yeah in terms of
where the numbers
now let's see our pitch video has been
seen I think over 1,800 times we have
over 200 renters so you know I don't
know what that percentage is but that's
the ratio 1800 views 200 renters the
movie itself is over 600 views and so
with the views though that's a
combination of the people renting the
film currently and we've also sent out
the movie to all of our Kickstarter
backers so they can watch the movie and
pretty much we're giving people
unlimited access to the film during this
run for a dollar so if people want to
see the movie more than once they can so
those are those are those early numbers
yeah okay good I mean that's you know
it's it's a start yeah we're happy you
know the whole point the whole point is
is you know a lot of people are you know
they're scared
you know like like putting these kind of
numbers out there like like um you know
people don't realize the amount of hard
work it takes to sell your work you know
and even if I'm only charging a dollar
it's hard to get people to buy your
movie for a dollar so you know I think
some people at this point in time they
look at what we've done and say wow
that's an utter failure other people
might be like wow that's incredible you
know to us you know whatever people may
think is fine you know we're happy with
the decision we're happy to have it
totally available to anyone in the world
we've had people watch the film in South
Africa we've had the film people watch
the film in England we've had our guy
Pablo Cuevas in Mexico at a laptop
computer with his friends gathered
around all watching the movie yeah enemy
true Roy in Pakistan has been like
when's it coming out when's it coming
out so you know just people all over
asking them yeah yeah so it's totally
totally cool you know and we'll see if
we can finish with a flurry and you know
may hopefully create some numbers that
maybe are a little bit more exciting for
people like you but I think it's
important not to neglect the amount of
work that's gone into
not just the campaign but also years of
putting out content you know through me
through our film Kurds outfit and also
to I mean trying we had a week run at
the downtown independent and the first
night was was amazing I mean it was
totally sold out but then subsequent
nights it was much harder to get people
there so it's not easy it's really a me
and then you think well okay then
there's reasoning
you know $12 or $10 for the movie ticket
at the parking the gas the popcorn all
that so you think $1 it's a no-brainer
and it's not it's not a no-brainer so
it's it's you know what what gets people
to that styling point where that buying
point where they'll pull out that credit
card and pull the trigger yeah well I do
I am curious are you guys planning on
tried to get this on Hulu and Netflix as
well as other VOD digital platforms no I
think we're definitely interested and we
just want to continue to see how how
this does you know we're not we're not
we're not we're not totally making your
minds at this point of time in the two
weeks we ride this all the way through
but you know there's advantages and
disadvantages to to Netflix
you know to Hulu and also it's easy to
say that but those are also platforms
that are not easy to get on - so Netflix
has made it incredibly difficult for
films like ours to get onto those
platforms you know you you generally
have to go through an aggregate or
district or distributor so so we'll see
you know we'll see we're just going to
ride this out for the next two weeks and
see what kind of opportunities continue
to come our way well I'm definitely
looking forward to seeing how you guys
progress with this because I'm watching
very closely oh yeah I mean it's it's
interesting you know again it's a it's
just another social experiment that's
that's how I'm trying to do it you know
it's just like leaving DVDs at the
7-eleven so you know we'll see what
happens and I think no matter how much
money is raised it's not a failure in
that it's a new way of doing it and it's
people work their curiosity's piqued and
it's very flattering for someone like
yourself to say that you want to try it
yourself you know and
we'll see and maybe somebody with a
bigger audience would actually succeed
more and if it's sort of a trailblazing
experiment that works and then somebody
like a louis c.k or whoever you have
someone who's had that success kind of
doing it on their own tries it that way
then all better very true yeah yeah so
yeah you know and we're still in the
process of telling our own story you
know and there's there some you know
there's some components that you know
behind the scenes that we haven't you
know you know there's always stuff that
happens you know so we're we're just you
know we're trying to put our best foot
forward just we're just trying to keep
this train moving and and just deal with
deal with everything we're dealing with
and meanwhile you know it's not easy to
be out in front of people like sort of
pushing you know pushing your product on
people for a long period of time you
know but at the same time that's what
you have to do and we had a chance to
speak with Tony Sierra of my big break
and and so we have a video series that
we did with him that we hadn't been able
to put online yet and one thing that he
said to us in that series was because
they're they're self distributing their
own there's so much tributing on Amazon
as well as dystrophy and really the only
time they see sales for the film is when
is when they push it themselves and it's
a film that has some name recognition it
has Chad Lindberg it has West Bentley so
you know you have some recognizable
stars in there and West Bentley was just
in Hunger Games but even with that you
know they're all the only really see
activity on the phone when they when
they get behind it and they push it
themselves so it's if that kind of
hustle it takes have you seen it Matt I
have not no oh I think you'd like it I
really do I think you love it
yeah you can watch the trailer on was it
my big break movie.com I think you'd
really like it no I'll definitely check
it out cuz I like watching stuff like
that cuz if it works it gives you hope
yeah but I mean also to is disagree I
opener on sort of the roast
business so it's a really cool film I
tell almost every actor I meet that'll
listen to me come on you know when you
see my big break and you see goodbye
promise you see this this other side of
Los Angeles this other side of Hollywood
that you that you normally you don't get
exposure to that for that world you know
it's just a different reality so it's
not it's not sort of that Cinderella
reality like it's more of like for
anyone that's been here for any length
of time it you know it's the kind of
stuff that we've been exposed to so you
know it's one of our favorite films that
we that we saw in 2011 and you know
we're happy to keep spreading the word
on that film so more people see it right
now let's definitely check it out yeah
so so my big break sleepwalk with me
goodbye
man you know if you have any other
questions we'll take them if now we're
gonna just thank you for for taking time
out of your day firing up the the
MacBook and having session with my real
quick if you if you go down to Hollywood
and do that I don't know I'd almost like
to be a fly on the wall and almost like
to see that I I need to get a wig and a
trench coat I've got the beard so but I
don't have a hair and I need some
cigarettes which are easy to get so
other than that yeah I think it should
be pretty easy to do cool all right well
maybe you know do some email exchanges
and see what I mean just be fun to watch
I love stuff like that so I I would do
it I'm not against making a sign and
standing on a street corner you know
trying to like I said it'd be like
homeless person be like will work to
make film you know just like trying any
Avenue you can try I think if people
just to see you in the trench coat that
is right back it's been done before it's
been done I it almost sounds like
something you could be hired to do you
know you could you could open up a
service where independent filmmakers
hire you that's a sort of you know
pulling off their movies you know down
Hollywood red dress there's like
atmosphere that I think is great
who's the Jason you look like that we
can get to go to that would be a little
trick here I got to find one of those
or you just bribe him to go down there
with like call of duty and he'll show up
yeah I was about to find someone that
maybe you could put a post on like
nowcasting or something and they do that
you guys get a skateboard and just yeah
I just go down there and then I want to
be a fly on the wall I want to watch and
film it I I will definitely make it a
spectacle if it happens that's good so
you know as being the conversation
matters is there anywhere we can direct
people on your behalf
where should we send them to check out
some of the stuff you have going on
right now just flash or shorts comm I've
got you know I'm running daily films on
there right now trying to get more
submissions because I usually get like
about 30 in a bulk so try to get more
for that and then just em Jarboe on
twitter is where I'm usually spending
most of my days okay cool and then did
you want to direct people to your film
that you said is on YouTube oh yeah yeah
it's alright totally forgot about that
it's a it's called in search of and it's
ISO - the movie comm and you can watch
it for free on there right now
cool thank you sir preciate the time
this afternoon we're still hoping you
know when things settle down and once we
figure things out we're hoping that to
meet up with you and talk a little bit
more about social media and some of the
things you have going on yeah yeah I'm
finishing up my book on social media
right now as well so that's going to be
fun when I'm drunk okay
I yeah you know live in LA you got to
keep working yeah